hola me llamo hola de guardia
vengo de damasco tengo 26 años llegué a
turquía en marzo de 2015
hola trata de llevar la vida de
cualquier joven de su edad actualmente
está estudiante que sueña con ser
arquitecta del paisaje está grabando un
vídeo para los cerca de 20.000 inscritos
a su cuenta de youtube
aquí puedo pensar en mi hacer cosas para
mí cosas que me gustan y que eran
difíciles de realizar en siria por
ejemplo tengo mi cuenta de vídeos y
youtube
me hace falta mi casa mi hermana mis
amigos mi familia todos están allá no
tengo televisión y no veo noticias
cuando quiero saber qué está pasando en
siria le pregunto a mi hermana oa mis
amigos trato de mantener la distancia
porque cuando hablan decir en la
televisión me siento mal me siento
triste no tiene esperanzas para así
diana
no creo que la situación va a mejorar no
está mal
ni me lo pregunto ni lo pienso tampoco
cojear me vale
o la fue escogida para participar en un
cortometraje que cuenta la historia de
una siria que se adapta a un nuevo país
aquí la gente tiene prejuicios muy
arraigados en contra de los sirios por
ejemplo cuando voy a visitar un
apartamento la gente me ve se da cuenta
de que soy una persona de bien pero no
me lo quieren arrendar porque soy sirio
no
más al del inec no no quiero volver a
ser yo porque allá no podría cumplir mis
sueños mi país es incapaz de asegurar lo
mínimo necesario para sus habitantes si
no hubiera habido guerra mi vida habría
sido tan diferente creo que me habría
conformado con una vida sencilla sin
peligros sin miedo hacia el futuro aquel
al mojado para aguantar